I remember reading
Alain De Botton's book
"The Art of Travel."
And I was extremely struck
by the power of this book
to make the suggestion--
to remind us,
rather-- that wherever
we go, you know,
whenever we head to
that "elsewhere",
to that anywhere-but-here,
we often
find that we have to bring
ourselves along for the ride.
We look at the
brochure, and we dream
about who we'll become
when we go to that place.
We dream about that beach.
We dream about that sunset.
We dream of what, of who, we
might become in that moment.
It's really about
hacking our reality.
The journey is really a
desire for self-transcendence,
a desire for rebirth, a
desire for apotheosis.
It's a very powerful thing.
It's a very hard thing to hack
because of hedonic adaptation.
Because familiarity,
because routines,
because traditional
modes of thought
blind us from the ecstasy
of the present moment.
They blind us from the
hardly bearable ecstasy
of direct energy exploding
in our nerve endings
when we dissolve
boundaries, when
we are here in the
Now-- inspired,
experiencing revelatory ecstasy,
making time dilate because
of the poetry of this moment.
We want that.
We seek that illumination,
that catharsis,
that moment of letting go, of
losing ourselves and finding
ourselves.
Of being inspired,
of being moved
to tears by this exquisite
italization of the moment.
And yet it's so hard.
So what do we do?
What do we do?
We create mantras, and we create
itineraries, and we do drugs--
but it's elusive.
That space, that liminal
space is so hard to tap into.
That flow.
I'm searching for it, man.
That's why I love
that word-- hermenaut.
The hermenaut, right?
Hermeneutics-- the
search for meaning.
Astronaut-- you
know what that is.
Hermenaut is us.
We are the travelers in
search of signification.